journée des femmes demain on vous a
demandé donc de réfléchir à ce sujet un
petit peu avant l'émission qui est
responsable de cette bonne idée le
coupable il est là c'est marc landré qui
m'a dit ce matin plutôt que de parler
des sujets comme le plafond vers les
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration et tout autre chose
tout aussi importante
il avait envie de nous faire partager
son coup de gueule à leurs marques
allez-y vous avez la parole chaque année
à ce moment à ce moment de l'année donc
pour lui mars pour la journée à 13 à des
femmes ou nous ressort un chiffre
il se trouve que c'est un des seuls
chiffres il augmenter le nombre de
femmes qui décèdent sous les coups de
leur conjoint ou d'un ex conjoint alors
un chiffre qui est très contesté
il se trouve que là il a évolué en
moyenne c'était une femme meurt sous les
coups de son conjoint tous les points
tous les deux jours et tous les trois
jours et maintenant ça serait passé
depuis le début de l'année suite à une
enquête d'un collectif sur facebook à
tous les deux jours au delà de au delà
de la véracité du chiffre le trouve que
c'est totalement scandaleux qu'on en
parle qu'une fois dans l'année dire au
moment de la journée de la femme et / ou
alors quand ce qu'il ya un drame qui
survient et que ça on fait la une des
médias
d'une manière générale c'est un scandale
que j ai encore une forme d'impunité ou
de scandale autour de ces choses là
autour des femmes qui skient qui meurt
sous les coups d'un conjoint
et avec ce chiffre c'est aussi celui des
enfants qui meurent de violence
conjugale c'est devant seulement et
encore je voyais que je sais plus son
prénom la jeune femme qui est morte
récemment encore ce qu'en fait elle
avait alerté à plusieurs reprises la
gendarmerie parce que son ex conjointe
était armé que ça m'inquiétait beaucoup
et que arnaud benedetti votre coup de
gueule votre carte mais en france une
carte blanche
disons le soutien qu'on doit accorder
aux femmes iraniennes qui s'efforce de
retirer leur voile et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la comparaison qu'on
peut faire avec l'occident où on est en
train de se battre notamment après la
sphère du vide jamais de décathlon ou au
nom d'une sorte de relativisme culturel
on est prêts finalement accepté des
formes de soumis de soumission nous qui
avons en occident inventé une forme
d'universalisme et que les pays qui sont
aujourd'hui
finalement des pays qui étaient en
dehors de cette forme d'universalisme
vous avez des femmes qui combattent pour
avoir la liberté tout simplement de
pouvoir circuler dans la rue sans un
voile je trouve que il y aquelques par
une presse qu'une parabole dans cette
comparaison que l'on peut faire entre un
occident qui parfois doutent de la
pertinence de ces valeurs et des femmes
qui dans d'autres cultures défendre ses
valeurs tout simplement au nom d'une
liberté qui s'appelle tout simplement la
liberté individuelle
voilà la parole en dernier
paradoxal mais bon donc je crois que
d'abord on peut faire les deux et que
c'est vrai que le mouvement mis tous là
encore à tracer une ligne
incontestablement ça a été extrêmement
positif et ça n'empêche pas évidemment
de se battre pour les droits des femmes
dans le reste du monde
ce sur quoi je voulais insister c'est
sur le fait qu' on a aujourd'hui 43 6 %
de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration justement et que ça
mais la france grâce à une loi quand
même c'est ma propre et parce qu'on dit
on dit souvent que la loi qui permet des
avancées et en l'occurrence c'est vrai
moi je ne suis pas un grand partisan des
quotas mais je suis le premier à dire
que en l'occurrence à fonctionner et
donc c'est que c'est très bien et ça met
la france aujourd'hui pratiquement la
première place mondiale
donc c'est positif on constate cependant
que l'état qui a donc fait passer cet
loi utile dans le secteur privé est
lui-même très en retard parce que si
vous regardez des ministères comme le
quai d'orsay ou surtout le ministère de
l'économie des finances
il ya un système d'amande pour les
ministères qui ne nomme pas suffisamment
de femmes à des postes de directeur et
donc notamment lemire le ministère des
finances va devoir payer 1,7 million
d'euros pour le retard en matière de
nomination de femmes à des postes de
directeur donc une fois de plus l'état
en l'occurrence à tout à fait jouer son
rôle vis-à-vis du secteur privé ça
serait bien qu'ils s'appliquent lui
aussi les règles qu'ils appliquent qu'il
entend légitimement faire respecter par
les entreprises est là le message est
passé
rachel dinas vous concluez je vais
conclure alors pas sur les violences
conjugales dont on parle beaucoup et je
pense pas seulement pas seulement une
fois par an ni par les femmes en
entreprise mais celles qui veulent
rester qui veulent être mère au foyer
je crois que c'est quelque chose dont on
ne parle pas du tout ou alors peut-être
pas assez certaine forme quasiment de
cécité de la part des politiques et des
féministes quand il s'agit de ces femmes
là pour qui la vie est devenue
extrêmement compliqué à cause d'un
capitalisme qui oblige aujourd'hui aux
deux époux de travail et tout est
calculé en fonction de en fonction de
deux revenus que ce soit les loyers que
ce soit un certain nombre un certain
nombre de tarifs
et alors quelques féministes considère
qu'en fait elles sont sous une forme de
domination ou d'aliénation
je crois qu'au lieu de forcer les femmes
forcément à sortir de chez elle pour
travailler en entreprise
on devrait également se poser la
question de celles qui veulent être mère
au foyer
restez à la maison élever leurs enfants
parce que c'est une forme de travail
quand vous en avez 3 4 5 ou plus qui
mérite aussi une forme de reconnaissance
et c'est pas une infériorité moral je
crois vous dites les deux fois les mêmes
financière pour que financière en
premier exactement sociétale et ce sont
des femmes qui ne sont pas défendus
aujourd'hui en fait est qu'ils ne sont
pas pu
du tout alors on sait en a journée de
demain elle est placée sous le signe je
crois il ya deux aspects je crois que
les violences conjugales et l'égalité au
travail
être mère au foyer ça peut être aussi un
travail je pense qu'on a tous des
exemples au sein de nos proches
peut-être démerder grand mère des soeurs
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce choix
aujourd'hui c'est un choix qui est
quasiment impossible ça fragilise sa
tragédie et la famille sa fragilité d'un
certain nombre d'institutions et et
c'est dommage donc voila j'aimerais
qu'on ait une dépense est une petite
pensée pour elle le message aussi sans
doute pas c'est grâce à vous tous merci
beaucoup d'avoir joué le jeu tous les
quatre merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
et vous avez rendez vous demain avec
guillaume roquette pour un nouveau point
de vue
[Musique]
bonjour et témoin à certain nombre
d'élus de la république en marche